we turn to the mercedes-benz vans phone
line right now the mr bracketology
himself kind enough to join us amidst a
busy march madness friday in advance of
the brackets coming out for the big
dance writ large joe linardi back here
on the rich eisen show how are you doing
joseph
i am great rich it's great to talk to
you as always
and uh yeah here we are
uh baseball football and even a little
college basketball in the news i do love
it i do love it even though i just want
to just front up just straight out joe i
will shoot you straight even though
you're my third guest today and you're
in the third hour you're a quad one
guest to me just so you understand wow
you're a quad one guest and you're
you know because i i i just got a note
that said
as as a host you were
first four out oh no
you must have got a note from management
back in 2003 there at espn
that must have been that must be that
must be that must be a 19 year old note
you found in a drawer desk drawer there
in bristol no no
no i'm i'm i'm still you know always i
feel happy to be on with you
this summer i played guff a couple times
with revere
network so you know fantastic we old
guys we got to stick together
well
it's great to see dave repson uh albeit
not delivering the the proper news
yesterday uh my alma mater getting
bounced in the first game that they
played in the big ten tournament uh tell
me about michigan i'm just going to go
straight to my own personal interests
before going writ large with you uh is
michigan in or out do you think right
now they're going to make it
i would say at this moment about 60 40
to not have to play in the opening
rounds of dayton
but we will see how that goes i seem to
be a little bit in the minority and
maybe over rating them
more than most uh maybe
might have something to do with the
whole lennardy martelly thing
uh but but but i'm i'm certainly trying
not to have that
come into play
uh i i just think
you know
we keep comparing michigan to last year
and to its own pre-season expectations
as opposed to the other bubble teams
that they're competing with
right and when you do that
they look a lot better all right so who
are the other bubble teams that they're
competing with then joe well wyoming
xavier wake forest now indiana which has
just posted
another big win even bigger than
yesterday against illinois uh
you know some of those teams are going
to go to dayton maybe one or two that
currently out
but surging like in virginia tech or in
oklahoma uh texas a m is trying to put
the finishing touches on auburn
uh and and then we'll hear well or i'm
sorry texas a m we'll hear what does
that mean for a m the real story is it
might cost auburn a one seat
uh
you know in in the drive for show putt
for dough category you got to focus on
you know the top because we're all going
to worry about upsets and double-digit
seeds and 12-5 and all that and you know
i'm as
vulnerable to doing that as anyone but
three four weeks from now when we're
talking sweet 16 final four
those are the scenarios at the very top
among the top two three four lines that
matter the most okay so joe linardi espn
bracketologist here on the rich eisen
show
so the um
the bubbles teams you just you've just
expressed
and then
everything you just said then um is
assuming we're not going to see
some team go on a run for the ages and
cut down a conference tournament net
that
is the only path for them to get into
the bracket right that's the only right
so let me give you the mask right now
right now
and and there's going to be all this
talk on the air by analysts and even
myself
i believe
that there are two spots in clay
two that's it currently held by xavier
and wake forest
and there are an unusually high number
at least in my view of teams in hot
pursuit
chasing those two spots
uh
a it's unusual to only have two up for
grabs at this point
and b it's scary because in your
scenario you know if if if
i don't know uh
uh
umass wins the atlantic 10 tournament
well then it's one spot
right if
you know if
somebody comes from off the board if
colorado wins the pac-12
tournament
yeah you know that's a spot if texas a m
runs a table now in in tampa at the sec
tournament that's just so
it could be that the committee's work at
the end of the line
is closer to being done than their
process would even allow them to realize
at this point how about uh because
because they're following
like a
a very methodical very necessary very
kind of checks and balances way to get
to the finish line of balancing the
the auto bid winners and
the available at larges
uh and and that line can and will move
all the way through sometimes even to
sunday afternoon but i have the luxury
being committee of one yes of peaking
ahead
right and and trying to envision the
scenarios
and it looks to me that
we're already running out of real estate
yeah
i mean i think it's fascinating as we're
watching all this you think there's just
barring nobody coming out of the blue
like a bolt of lightning flying the
ointment whatever you want to say
um there's only two spots really that
are are kind of on
uh shaky ground uh that's
kind of wild for me
you know just
again
back to the envelope
from years past what i remember we're
usually not at that stage i don't think
at lunch time on friday
uh which of course means i'm probably
way way off
and
you know the miami dolphins are going to
be the last team who knows maybe this is
a year of a curveball in the dirt
joe leonard espn bracketologist here on
the rich eisen show okay so your best
crystal ball of the top seeds
um and i know things can change but uh
it does appear
my eyesight shows me it's like an
eight-point lead texas a m has on auburn
right now in the sec tournament
so what do you think
yeah that looks like that's gonna happen
all right well
it's one thing to lose and not gain
ground it's another thing to be passed
by somebody who's done better or more
than you so at this moment i'm still
going to go with the top line in order
of gonzaga arizona
kansas and baylor baylor having lost
but
dropping from
uh
second overall to fourth overall in
doing so
auburn was fifth overall in prime
position to take advantage of baylor now
kentucky is in that kind of co-pilot
seat of next up
and and if
uk goes on
and wins the sec tournament
and
you know kansas gets let's say the final
of the big 12.
i think
and i thought all week that we would
have
after the two west coast teams gonzaga
and arizona we would have
last man standing from the sec and last
man standing for the big 12
on the top line i i i think that at some
point
that's just common sense
when the the resumes and and all the
accounting exercises that we do
are you know within the margin of error
and close enough like like the logic is
did you just won something
right
you know if kansas and kentucky win
their respective conference tournaments
and auburn and baylor go out in the
quarterfinals that that should
mean something i know it's body of work
i know
november's supposed to count as much as
march etc etc
but but there's also a common sense
element to this how's michael how's
vital doing
how's he doing i i don't have any new
information
other than
you know what he put out a couple days
ago where it was
phenomenal miraculous news
uh and you know i'm sure you share the
view that we all do that
you know
for all the good he's done for our sport
and even more so for
for for
children in pediatric cancer right
good lord you know he deserves a bounce
in his direction i agree i love that but
i i have to say yeah i have to say it
has been quieter
i did see some videos of it that he's
been doing and he just looks and he
sounds great you know i know you know
rich they're going to be saying the same
thing about me someday you know what joe
you're you're the best
this is your tax season man enjoy it
thanks for the call appreciate it joe
hey thanks for having me anytime be well
you bet that's joe linardi right here
all right joe says michigan's in and
we're in and you're back
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here